the president of the european friends of
memories of life
absolutely and yes the systematic
extermination of six million jews
is absolutely evil absolutely evil that
i cannot put into words the
worst barbarism that
man can inflict on man the
breaking of nazi germany against
humanity and as a german i feel
heavy guilt and yet i speak here
the victims to whom we bow
were killed in the name of my nation
the sites of this murder were spread
all over europe
auschwitz beech forest barber mauthausen
bergen belsen treblinka names of
unimaginable humanity
crimes and loss  of all
humanity we commemorate today the
tormented and disenfranchised of the
national socialist tyranny
we commemorate millions of murdered
european jews the roma sinti the
forced
laborers jehovah's witnesses the homosexuals the
sick and disabled the political
prisoners and  the prisoners of war and
many many others
we bow to the dead
yes as a german i feel a special
guilt but i also feel a special
responsibility
because as a german in europe i
also know that it was our neighbors who shook hands with
us and took us in
again  have in the circle
of democratic peoples and uncle ben
cottreau in joseba beloki absolut the
prosthesis ladin etat violeta valéry
the compact but determination tut form
of discrimination
july
[applause]
huge moral
[music]
discriminating
[applause]
the 75th anniversary of the liberation of the
auschwitz camp  is we
commemorate all those whose future was
wiped out
we commemorate all those who never returned from the camps
a million and a half
jewish children were
murdered
and i weep for every child and it has
its name in jad vashem
we commemorate those but also those who
survived and  dear liliana
segre those who remember the terrible  struggles against
this hell
are
burned into our memories forever but this commemoration is also a call to vigilance
heinz galinski the longstanding
chairman of the central council of jews in
germany rightly said i
quote democracy cannot be
imposed on any society it is also
not a gift that one receives  once and for all
it has to be fought for and defended every
day end of quote and that's what it's all about
resist the beginnings be vigilant
we are sincere about our
history we defend the
inviolability of the dignity of every
single human being we defend the
innermost being and the values of our
democracy we owe it to the victims of
the holocaust we
owe it to human dignity as well as
to our democracy thank you
very much [applause]